so let's continue talking about Jared
Kushner we learned that trump advisor
and son-in-law Jared Kushner has had his
interim top-secret security clearance
removed he now has an interim secret
security clearance it's a small victory
but it is a small victory that exposes
that this is not normal and that we've
got some major problems here and all
over the media yesterday you had experts
speculating that when you have someone
like Kushner with business ties all over
the world with debts to all sorts of
people all over the world that when you
put him in a position of both power and
access to sensitive information that
it's a major risk and that it exposes
him to being manipulated or squeezed or
pressured by people that he's working
with from other countries even if
Kushner is no longer running his
businesses he still has financial
interests in those businesses and he
still knows how geopolitical events and
decisions might impact those businesses
if you're in another country could be a
friendly country could be a less
friendly country and you know what Jared
Kushner's business ties are and his
financial troubles and you know that the
guy has an interim top-secret security
clearance you can use that to your
advantage when dealing with Kushner and
the great thing is we don't have to
speculate about this anymore because the
Washington Post has a report exposing
that at minimum four countries have been
talking about how they could manipulate
Jared Kushner on the basis of his
business arrangements and his financial
trouble and his basic total lack of
foreign policy experience we know
specifically because of reporting from
the Washington Post of the United Arab
Emirates the UAE China Israel and Mexico
at the minimum according to current and
former officials and more than likely
there are other countries as well who
were discussing how to take Jared
Kushner's circumstances and manipulate
him to their advantage is this
surprising absolutely not
any experienced foreign policy team
would recognize
has no place in international deployment
diplomacy he represents a huge risk to
the United States because of his
background now do we know whether these
four countries or others acted on their
ideas to manipulate Jared Kushner no we
don't know that but what we do know is
that this could end up having some
pretty significant legal implications
special special prosecutor Robert Muller
we know has been investigating the
conversations that Jared Kushner had and
protocols that he used to set up
conversations with foreign leaders we
know that Robert Muller is interested in
financially what is in the background of
Jared Kushner and even officials at the
White House have expressed concern that
Kushner was being tricked
that's a quote tricked in conversations
with foreign officials we've also
learned that some foreign leaders were
being specific in requesting that they
wanted to deal only and directly with
Jared Kushner which is really alarming
because it's not Jared Kushner's sense
of humor that's making him appealing for
other countries to deal with
it's that his inexperience and his
naivete are making him a great target
for other countries to deal with and
from the beginning and it was always
inappropriate for Kushner and Ivanka
Trump by the way to be involved in this
administration and what I'm hoping is
that Kushner's sort of window of
opportunity for even being involved in
this administration is starting to close
if he's indicted the window will be
hopefully slammed shut but are we
starting to see the sunsetting of Jared
Kushner and Ivanka's role in this
administration I don't know about Ivanka
but I think Jared Kushner son is
definitely setting and I think the
lesson here the takeaway is that if
you're gonna have someone who is so
compromised and so inexperienced in your
administration yeah just put him in
charge of domestic issues like yeah
right Berman ethics reform and criminal
justice reform and solving the opioid
crisis that's enough for Kushner yeah
and I think he'd still be out of his
league by the way doing this things
sadly speaking uh but yeah there's no
credible way to defend him having the
role that he has and based on what we
know now I mean lying multiple times
that sf-86 disclosure form having his
interim security clearance downgraded
being targeted for manipulation by other
countries this guy can't negotiate trade
he's certainly not gonna be negotiating
israeli-palestinian peace which I don't
know what the timeline was for him
solving that one but I think we're
further from the solution rather rather
than closer to it I wouldn't want this
guy negotiating my car lease
never mind Middle East peace and the
question now is I mean I guess there's
really two questions for me is this
unraveling to the point where it will be
untenable to keep him on I don't know
because Trump does have what I guess we
can characterize as quote loyalty to the
family so I don't know that Trump will
actually push him out I think it will be
sort of incumbent upon maybe Kushner's
lawyer or his circle to go listen
Trump's not gonna fire you
because you're his son-in-law which by
the way is a reason you shouldn't even
be doing this in the first place but you
should probably step away for the good
of the country or he might just be
indicted right and honestly I don't even
know that Trump would push him out if he
was indicted because he would just say
it's a witch hunt and he can stay but
again I'm trying to imagine how
reasonable people would act and these
are not reasonable people but if under
indictment you would hope that Kushner
would say I've got to deal with the
indictment I can't be negotiating
israeli-palestinian peace I can't be
negotiating trade deals or whatever else
I don't know the answer but my hope is
and the correct path forward would be
that Kushner and his role in this
administration start to evaporate and
I'm actually going to talk about what
might already be set up as a soft
landing for Kushner a little bit later
in the program discuss this or any other
stories from the show with more than
5,000 of our viewers and listeners on
our subreddit at david pakman.com slash
our EDD IT today's episode of the
program is made possible in part by
brilliant which is really a fantastic
and unique online service that has sort
of reinvented the way people learn math
and science if you watch the show you're
already probably generally curious about
how the world works and you like to
learn new
things maybe you have a sort of casual
interest in physics or solar energy or
AI philosophy computer science but
you're ready to take it to the next
level and whether you already have a
grasp on these subjects or you want to
engage and acquaint yourself with these
topics for the first time brilliant is
the place to go you can actually learn
hands-on by solving problems and puzzles
that were designed by expert educators
and professionals and you can start
right now sign up for free at brilliant
org slash David Pakman the first 200
people who visit brilliant org slash
David Pakman will get 20% off an annual
premium membership that is brilliant org
forward slash David Pakman